[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
dès qu'une merde tu n'aurais jamais dû
naître tu n'as pas été désiré ou encore
tuer une traînée chaque jour femme
enfant et homme sont confrontés à des
violences psychologiques et morales
intrafamiliales alors qu'est-ce qu'une
violence morale et commence en protéger
pour en parler avec nous je reçois
aujourd'hui Chantal Paoli Texier
présidente de l'association AGC bonjour
bienvenue sur sensation en association
avec TV 78 bonjour Alors j'ai pu donner
quelques exemples d'insultes auxquels de
nombreux citoyens et citoyens sont
confrontés chaque jour et enfants une
liste non exhaustive qui ne compte pas
les insultes les plus rudes tout au long
de l'année l'association agissait lutte
pour les droits des victimes de
violences morales intrafamiliale alors
qu'est-ce qu'une violence morale et
quand commence-t-elle alors nous on a
choisi le terme générique de violence
morale pour regrouper la violence
psychologique la manipulation et le
harcèlement parce que ce sont des formes
de violence qui s'intrigue qui sont
complètement
tellement noués entre elles que on a du
mal à définir ce qui est de l'ordre de
la violence psychologique ce qui est de
l'ordre de la contrainte qui serait la
manipulation et ce qui est de l'ordre de
la réitération qui serait le harcèlement
donc on a regroupé toutes les formes de
violence qui ne sont pas des violences
physiques sous ce terme-là donc en fait
ça comporte c'est vraiment une
déclinaison qui est assez
impressionnante parce que ça va de
effectivement de tout ce qui est
violence verbale de tous les insultes
humiliation des nègrement mais aussi ça
passe par les regards
la négation de l'existence de l'autre
d'ailleurs c'est une violence invisible
puisque on n'a pas de trace physique de
de cette violence pourtant elle est tout
aussi meurtrière presque des gens se
suicident à cause de cette violence
morale alors est-ce que la justice
justement aujourd'hui ne devrait pas
faire un peu plus d'efforts pour
reconnaître cette violence la justice
elle a des efforts énormes à faire pour
la reconnaître et puis la prendre en
considération à sa juste valeur enfin
façon de parler justement du fait que
avec une violence qui est très
destructrice qui déshumanisante c'est
pas mon terme à moi c'est un terme qui a
été employé par Toby Nathan en parlant
de l'emprise et il avait tout à fait
raison c'est une une violence qui vous
prive de ce que vous êtes profondément
et intrinsèquement vous avez vous êtes
privé de votre libre arbitre vous êtes
privé de vos repères vous êtes privé de
vos choix et vous êtes privé aussi de
vos normes c'est une violence qui est
très semblable à celle des sectes en
fait
si la violence physique est entre
guillemets un plus simple à approuver
les violences morales ne sont pas du
tout visibles c'est ce qu'on disait il y
a un instant est-ce qu'une preuve audio
ou des témoignages peuvent justement
aider les victimes à se défendre devant
un juge alors toute preuve audio
enregistrement même même vidéo
et témoignages des familles sont
recevables au pénal par contre il est
beaucoup plus difficile de produire ses
preuves aussi civiles et nous avons
quand même majoritairement des victimes
qui ont affaire aux juge aux affaires
familiales ou au juge des enfants mais
pas du tout au procureur et en
correctionnelle donc c'est
la charge de la preuve elle est
extrêmement compliquée en matière de
violence morale les victimes doivent
prouver qu'elles sont belles et bien
victimes ce qui est quand même assez
c'est une nouvelle violence en fait
c'est comme si on rajoutait de la
culpabilité et de la honte et du doute à
la culpabilité là honte et le doute
tourner encore un petit peu le couteau
dans sa propre dans sa propre plaie
finalement alors une question un petit
peu difficile comment est-ce qu'on peut
reconnaître qu'on est victime de
violence morale intrafamiliales et
surtout quand on est extérieur à ça
quand on est témoin finalement d'une
violence comment est-ce qu'on peut faire
prendre conscience à la personne alors
selon constat ce sont beaucoup plus les
témoins qui vont prendre conscience
qu'il y a de la violence face à eux les
victimes bien souvent et trop souvent
même quand elles arrivent à
l'association n'ont pas tout à fait
conscience parce qu'elles sont si pertes
de repères quelles sont véritablement
victimes de violences mais est-ce que
c'est pas moi qui des raisonne est-ce
que c'est pas moi qui suis folle est-ce
que je me fais pas des idées est-ce que
et ça c'est typiquement le propos d'une
victime justement de ce responsabiliser
de croire que tout est de sa fausse
culpabiliser donc quand on est dans un
système où justement on n'arrête pas de
se dire
mais je fais mal les choses qu'est-ce
que je pourrais faire de mieux pour
qu'il soit heureux etc c'est que là il y
a déjà des problématiques qui il y a
déjà des le lien relationnel n'est pas
n'est pas sain n'est pas bon et donc il
faut commencer à se poser des questions
après les témoins agir et très très
compliqué parce que bien souvent quand
on intervient frontalement en disant
mais enfin tu te rends pas compte il est
fou quand même c'est vous êtes sûr et
certain que la victime va se figer et
qu'elle va au contraire défendre
l'auteur donc il faut y aller beaucoup
plus
subtilement en amenant la personne à
réfléchir et surtout en lui disant mais
est-ce que tu accepterais ça chez
quelqu'un d'autre est-ce que si moi j'y
vais ça tu tu n'interviendrais pas et en
étant précis dans les faits en plus
parce que il faut vraiment être factuel
pour pouvoir permettre aux victimes
d'identifier qu'il y a quelque chose qui
ne fonctionne pas normalement alors vous
accompagnez notamment les enfants
injectent de violences morales c'est un
peu plus délicat car les enfants sont
souvent avec leurs parents et souvent
c'est les parents eux-mêmes qui sont les
auteurs les harceleurs alors comment ça
se passe lorsqu'un enfant est victime et
qui peut vous contacter et comment
est-ce que vous l'accompagnez cet enfant
alors ce sont les parents victimes qui
nous contactent et qui et qui nous amène
leurs enfants et après nous on va leur
proposer différentes formes
d'accompagnement donc des tutorats
individuels si nécessaire des suivis
plus particuliers sur le trauma avec de
l'EMDR
ou des groupes de parole parce que les
groupes de parole ça fonctionne très
très bien avec les enfants parce que ce
sont c'est parler père qu'on comprend
mieux et qu'on identifie mieux la
violence et là le propre des groupes de
paroles enfants ce qui est intéressant
c'est de mélanger des enfants qui sont
sous emprise et qui n'arrivent pas à
définir ce que c'est qu'une violence et
des enfants qui eux ont dénoncé les
violences n'ont pas été forcément
protégées mais au moins les ont dénoncé
ces groupes de paroles donc il y a des
groupes de paroles pour enfants des
groupes de paroles pour pour adultes
c'est leur comment se constituent un
groupe de parole et qui est-ce qu'il y a
des professionnels justement pendant ces
groupes de paroles pour aider à la
Libération justement de la groupe de
parole c'est un groupe de partage et
d'échanges avec quand même un objectif
nous on a toujours cet objectif très
précis en tête de les inscrire dans
quelque chose de positif donc on
pratique la psychologie positive par des
jeux par des activités les groupes de
parole adultes sont des groupes de
paroles qui durent 4h donc c'est ce
mouvement des groupes où on a le temps
de s'installer de vraiment échanger
de pouvoir bénéficier de l'expérience
des uns et des autres
d'être beaucoup dans la bienveillance et
alors pour constituer ces groupes de
parole en règle générale nous on a un
planning qu'on diffuse et qu'on diffuse
aussi à nos partenaires et les gens
s'inscrivent librement par contre si ne
sont pas adhérents de l'association ils
ont à passer d'abord un entretien
préalable avant de pouvoir participer à
un groupe de parole et on va parler plus
largement de vos accompagnements donc on
a parlé on a des groupes de parole quels
sont vos autres accompagnements que vous
proposez alors l'accompagnement
majoritaire à l'association ce sont ce
qu'on appelle nous des tutorat parce
qu'on se compare à des tuteurs de
résilience donc on va pas parler ni de
ni de suivi ni de thérapie mais de
tutorat et puis parce que ça revait
plusieurs formes il y a des tutorats
spécifiques sur le trauma avec des
thérapies EMDR benzpotting pratiqué par
des spécialistes et puis il y a des
thérapies enfin ce qu'on fait quand même
de la thérapie puisque majoritairement
ce sont des psychologues qui
accompagnent qui font les tutorats
des thérapies qui sont des thérapies
humanistes tournées vers l'autre notre
objectif c'est l'individuation de la
personne c'est lui faire retrouver son
humanité lui faire le faire redevenir
sujet et acteurs de sa vie donc les
tutorats servent à ça mais on propose
aussi donc les groupes de parole on
propose aussi des ateliers et on
introduit petit à petit alors en 2023 on
a des gros projets donc j'espère qu'on
va arriver à les mettre mais produits
d'autres activités avec soit des
partenaires soit par nous-mêmes là il y
a deux des psychologues qui veulent
mettre en place en TCC
un travail de confiance sur confiance en
soi
après on a quelqu'un qui nous propose
par exemple du yoga donc pourquoi pas
créer des partenariats pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que les gens aient une
caisse à outils dans laquelle ils
puissent puiser pour être mieux et pour
pouvoir effectivement redevenir acteur
de sa vie et très rapidement si on
devait donner un conseil justement aux
personnes victimes de violences morales
intrafamiliales c'est d'en parler de se
libérer d'en parler la première des
choses c'est en parler oui effectivement
c'est trouver quelqu'un une oreille
attentive et bienveillante et en parler
c'est lire aussi mais en parler surtout
et justement votre association propose
d'en parler de se libérer pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur
agissez violence ce point org merci
beaucoup Chantal Paoli taxi d'avoir été
avec nous sur sensation donc je rappelle
que vous êtes la présidente de
l'association agissée si vous êtes
victime de violence physique sexuelles
ou morale de numéro existe le 119 pour
les enfants le 39-19 pour les femmes et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]